welcome back to our post game press
conference we've got the cast of 80 for
Brady here Jane Fonda
right now everybody
played a great interview today I feel
let's take some questions from the Press
let's start with Nick where are you nick
uh Kelly right here thank you so much
Nick kruppke from Fox 12 Oregon this
question is for Jane earlier we saw Rita
say that she called you for instructions
in bed you had a curious look on your
face just wanted to know what was going
through your mind at that moment and do
you have tips
tips tips
yes I did not say that I have two I I
have not and I never will
have tips for Rita
[Laughter]
Lily
they're just asking about the wrong
person that's all
right where is Mark Mark are you
mcloone Arizona's family hey uh so much
was discussed today wondering the
proudest moment in the discussion and
this question is for the whole panel
what you would have said and done maybe
differently and we'll start with you
Lily oh my gosh uh well that's why I
didn't join in it was
because you were insane
it was hard to compete with the uh
absolute uninhibited ex exposure
[Laughter]
but I've always looked to them as
influences
and I've hung on every word that they've
said
[Applause]
all right let's go to Mario what's your
question Mario yeah Mario Solis NBC4 Los
Angeles this question is for Rita you
came out of the gate strong dancing out
of the helmet as a veteran in this game
do you think it it sort of set the stage
for the rest of the uh that wasn't my
intention I heard music I moved
that's what I do when I hear music
[Applause]
Kelly and I have a follow-up okay so the
follow-up would be uh any of you wish
that you had also danced out like Rita
oh God no
I do not no we all go out of our way to
give Rita we have to give Rita her space
that's right yes her hips don't lie I've
been trying very hard behind her to
dance I guess it didn't register I have
a question for one of you whoever wants
to answer this I have a problem and it
came up a little bit during the game now
about tight ends
[Laughter]
don't know what it means
could you explain I want one but I don't
know quite what it is
so
she appears to have found her it's so
tight
it's so tight and that's a real question
on a football team it's a position on a
football team it's a person that plays a
tight end position yeah but they're not
on the body but wait but wait they're
not the wide receiver why is it called
tight end because he's because he's
tighter in he's closer he's closer and
always Tighter and okay he's closer
right he's closer in yeah a little
closer to them
what is there sort of like a little
short
it was only like two or three guys in
there and they've all got tight ends and
they're
exactly
you do some Jane Fonda working now
that's what you do
that's how I got my Titans okay that is
our show a big thank you to the cast of
Eddie from ladies
in our audience and thank you as well to
Stephen A Smith you love the Cowboys I
feel it his book straight shooter and
Memoir of Second Chances and First Take
is in stores now go pick it up y'all
have a great day and if it's not try and
change it
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
I'm going
[Music]